[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is the iPhone 11 so it's a solid
improvement over the iPhone 10 are in a
couple ways it's a bit cheaper than the
pros now it's got a price drop so this
is the new iPhone that most people
should buy that was easy to easy
actually that this everything about this
phone is so easy like it's gonna be
super easy to review because there's so
few things but such obvious things that
are different from the 10r and of course
this is a super easy phone for Apple to
make and so this is a super easy phone
to recommend maybe this is the easiest
video I've ever had to make
but probably not let's just get into it
so the design is very familiar with this
one because it's the same as the 10 R
and the 10s and the 10 same shape same
notch same size as the 10 R it's still a
pretty big phone the same mute switch
same speakers same aluminum rails the
same lightning port same LCD display
with the 1792 by 8:28 resolution that
has us all questioning a lot of things
like not being able to watch HD YouTube
videos on a $700 phone but hey people
oven reviewers didn't seem to mind a lot
last year same water resistance same
ip68 same buttons you get the idea so
okay what is new first of all the name
so they're calling it just iPhone 11 so
it's the de-facto standard name now and
that also means they're dropping the
Roman numerals which is also probably
fine because we all know a couple people
that just called it the ex over and over
that's okay and the iPhone 11 has six
new colors so black green yellow purple
red and white and they're all more
pastel II so at the product red this
year is a little lighter than the
product red from last year I personally
liked the color choices of last year's
10 are more actually I think the blue is
pretty nice the coral was really unique
but those are all gone now but I guess
there's still a little bit of something
for everyone if you are looking to get a
little closer to that stealth midnight
green look but don't want to spend the
money on the 11pro you could always grab
a darker
skin from our channel sponsor debrand
and boom you got yourself a stealthy new
iphone for $715 instead of a thousand i
will of course always drop a link right
below that like button but if you rock
your phone naked like me you will notice
there are two different glass finishes
on the back of the iPhone 11
there's glossy like normal across the
back where the Apple logo is now in the
middle instead of slightly north of the
middle but the camera square is actually
a matte glass finish now so the opposite
of the 11pro which did a matte phone and
a glossy camera square and you might
already known that but what you might
not know is that they're all cut from
one piece of glass that's milled down to
cut the shape out of it and then two
different finishes so that's pretty cool
no matter what you think of the shape
and then we'll get to of course these
cameras in a second but the size and the
thickness and weight are exactly the
same as the 10r so it's still 8.3
millimeters thick still 194 grams
according to Apple site but you do now
have a battery life that according to
Apple is one hour longer than the iPhone
10 are now again I don't measure battery
the same way Apple does but the iPhone
10 are already had some of the best
battery life in any iPhone in a really
long time and it was the reason that a
lot of people who got it kept it and
switched to it so I can confirm that the
11 has at least equivalent battery life
to the 10r as it should now that it has
a more efficient a 13 Bionic so then the
only other thing that's new is the
cameras and this is easily the biggest
new thing about these so there's a new
main camera and they'd added a second
camera to the iPhone 11 and it's the
ultra wide so you now get dual cameras
and all the awesome features that come
with it like switching between lenses
while recording video so you get 4k
video from the regular and from the
ultra wide camera iPhone 11 dose
portrait mode now with more than just
human faces so it doesn't have to detect
a face to do the fake shallow depth of
field with animals and objects and other
things like that and there's also a new
wider front-facing camera that can take
slow slow motion videos it can take it
slow motion selfie videos if you want to
huh so the only thing that's missing is
you don't get the third telephoto camera
from the iPhone 11 pro that's not a huge
deal to me and both of these two new
included cameras are excellent they're a
plus smartphone cameras in 2019 I do go
into more detail on the photo and video
quality in the iPhone 11 Pro review for
these new cameras so if you want to
check that out I'll link it below but
suffice to say this is the best camera
in a $700 smartphone debatably arguably
the best in any smartphone but I still
think it's sort of a toss-up with the
pixel 3 but then again this has the
ultra wide camera that the pixel 3
doesn't but also the pixel 4 depending
on when you watch this is right around
the corner so we get to the full camera
comparison when they all come out but
for now if you want a great camera this
is a great camera and then they changed
the price they dropped the price so
iPhone 11 now starts that and this is
for 64 gigs and I think most people or a
lot of people should upgrade from that
but it starts at 700 bucks now which
sort of fits nicely in this gradient of
iPhone prices that Apple has created now
that they've kept around the 10r from
last year for cheaper and the iPhone 8
for even cheaper and that is pretty much
everything you need to know that's new
with this iPhone 11 easy iPhone 11 is an
iPhone 10 are with a slightly new design
new cameras with an extra camera on the
back a slightly better battery and a new
chip as it now the question is do you
recommend it and I think the easy answer
is yeah this is the iPhone that most
people should get but for a little more
nuance I think you should really ask
yourself two questions one how much do
you really care about the quality of
this screen the biggest weakness of this
phone is definitely still the display
and again a lot of people won't even
notice and the YouTube app I noticed
even lies to you and lets you pick 1080p
as if you're watching a 1080p video but
you're not it's like I said just over
720p so if you look at the iPhone 10
hour display or if you look at this
iPhone 11 in a store and you can tell
it's not sharp or you really value a
great display and you know it I'd say
pick one of the pie resolution OLED I
phones the 10s or the 11 Pro and then
the other number two is just the size
how do you feel about the size of this
phone I actually really liked that the
iPhone 11 pro is a relatively compact
smart phone by today
standards anyway so if you look at like
the 6.1 inch screen size and it's
actually too big if you've handled an
iPhone 11 or 10 R then you could go for
the slightly smaller better display in
the iPhone 11 Pro which will cost you
more but it's smaller or if you think
it's not big enough you can go for the
bigger iPhone 11 Pro Maxx
oh and there's another one actually
which is just all you want to budget
which just generally will put a lot of
people in the camp of buying the cheaper
iPhone but combo breaker they are still
selling iPhone 8 and iPhone 10 are and I
think iPhone 10 are at 600 bucks
is more competitive if you don't care
about the second camera or the camera
upgrade small group of people but if you
have to get an iPhone that's one to
consider but that is pretty much it they
did it they made an iPhone 11 that's
easy to recommend and it's the new
iPhone that people buying a new iPhone
should probably just get but that's what
happens when you make some improvements
on one of your most popular products and
drop the price a bit and rename it to
just the de-facto iPhone but I also
can't let you forget the weight of the
20/20 iPhone is heavy on the horizon and
it's definitely too early to get excited
for that it's another year away for that
phone but that's where I'm looking
either way thanks for watching this
super easy video and I'll catch you guys
in the next one peace
[Music]